when margarita can see no I just went  off the wrong side had to run her  apartment first came to Hollywood it was  a heck of a thing an agent described her  is neither short nor tall but more like  115 pounds of warm smoke and that smoke  is drifted in here tonight to present  the directors award  ladies and gentlemen a gifted actress  one of our great great stars miss Rita  Hayworth  you  thank you  those nominated for best achievement in  directing our Elia Kazan for America  America Otto Preminger for the Cardinal  said Oh Rico Fellini for Federico  Fellini's eight and a half  Martin rich for HUD Tony Richards to Tom  Jones and here's the winner the winner  is Tony Richards the palm dome  excepting for Tony Richardson  I'm so happy to take this back for tell  me it was a very richly deserved award I  think and we're very grateful indeed to  you for giving it to him thank you very  much  you